[Music]
in the modern world technology is
inescapable people spend all day at
their computers life today there's just
one big video game the pixels on their
screens make them feel joy sadness other
emotions I can't think of right now Oh
Matt oh you almost ran into me oh sorry
I was just thinking about society
tomorrow god really gets in your head
doesn't that yeah I just got to the
episode last night where the guard risk
makes Barbra kill herself oh it sounds
like there was a momentary lapse in
judgment and a mistake was made so I
think all we need is an apology I'm
sorry I spoiled an episode for you I
accept your apology that's nice yes I
actually took some initiative and
investigated the cause of the layoffs
and I think I found a way to save
thousands of jobs Wow Jake how did you
have time to do this and also watch
society tomorrow oh yeah I didn't watch
it
[Music]
Jake I specifically instructed you to
watch society tomorrow I know I just
thought this was more important to
forget everything you think is important
there is a storm coming
and when it comes none of us will be
safe least of all you
that's a line from episode three dude
you got to watch but also there are
going to be layoffs so that line does
kind of apply to you
and then there was just like blood and
guts everywhere race I need to file a
formal complaint here no I'm sorry Jake
the cinematography was just so cinematic
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're gonna keep watching the show I
am not giving you a ride to work
tomorrow and I was planning on stopping
for doughnuts and I am not glad
[Music]